aa alors monica ca va bien très bien
j'ai pas vu vincent cassel depuis
blueberry donc vous allez remplacer on
va faire une interview vincent cassel
bonsoir vincent cassel
ça me fait très plaisir de vous recevoir
comment allez-vous très bien vous avez
laissé pousser vous je veux bah oui pour
un rôle plus à faire les 14es pour un
voyage je suis prête à tout bien écrit
aussi vincent simplement vous trouvez
bola moi je suis pas [ __ ] mais le bouc
bel air radieux c'est l'amour qui vous
rend comme ça bah oui ça se passe bien
que monica oui vous êtes content d'avoir
un enfant avec elle ici
ces rallyes ça vous plaît d'être papa
absolument le faire d'autres enfants
avec elle magister qu'est ce que ça fait
quand on entend répéter toute la journée
que sa femme est la plus belle femme du
monde
ouais qu'est ce que vous aimez chez
monica l'instant mais qu'est ce qu'elle
a dit qu'est ce qu'elle a de plus beau
selon vous
vous êtes jaloux ah oui c'est normal
c'est vrai qu'il cherche bernard campan
partout pour la mort et d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
elle
il ya d un film de monica que vous
n'avez pas aimé vincent mai dernier film
de blier j'ai vraiment adoré
il est bien il faut dire que c'est un
bon blier l'adorait vraiment j'ai plongé
des dangers trouver les films
incroyables je crois que pour la
carrière de monica c'est très bien sont
en effet j'ai pensé qu'ils aient
vraiment je l'avais jamais vu comme ça
est ce que vous payez monica souvent
vincent non pas vraiment parce qu'il
tourne à vide est encore en tournage à
lui était en mongolie là était mongolie
il avait rentré il ya prenait tournée du
coup il travaillera la et vincent vous
draguez toujours un peu vous quand même
ben oui non mais je reste quand même un
homme s'est même sens il faut regarder
les autres simples pour apprécier la
sienne
vincent sérieusement si elle partait
vous feriez quoi j'ai lavé serez libre
c'est la seule manière pour qu'ils
retournent au prj mal un seul instant
qu'elle fait il a changé
il va parler comme ça il ya encore six
mois ici connais un sexuellement ça se
passe bien avec monica vincent très bien
vous avez fait quoi pour la séduire 26
ans
j'étais juste une semaine avant c'est
embêtant pour les autres qu'est ce que
vous détestez le plus chez vous vincent
mon côté feu qu est ce si ma force
notre principal défaut c'est quoi
vincent et rois et royaumes ça se dit
chez nous mais ça doit se dire non mais
attends c'est laurent est très marrante
ils disent ah ouais parce que moi aussi
je me sens un peu ivres ou à quelqu'un
qui est déjà beaucoup d'énergie en
italie on dit rires ouais c'est normal
vous avez peur qu'elle vous trompez
licka on arrive vers l'art compan il est
sûr de lui accorder
il ya des choses que vous aimeriez dire
à monica vincent ce soir revient déjà
dans tous les cas merci vincent remet
quand vous voulez je trouve super mini
ali